Walter it looks as though you've had a
crystal ball changing strategies to
attract a more mass-market customer and
here we are where we could be facing a
recession speak to us about that
strategy and how it's playing out at a
time when people are looking to save
well I think we're doing both good
morning to you guys I think we are
investing in our in really expanding
Whole Foods Market in thoughtful ways
and strategic ways at the same time as
we're launching we're excited launched
our second banner 365 by Whole Foods
Market which a smaller more curated
selection and excellent price points and
we think it's a way of bringing our
best-in-class quality standards for the
world in two wonderful formats do you
run the risk it's a style drift excuse
me do you run the risk that it's a style
drift it's not originally who Whole
Foods was well of course there's always
that there's always that risk with a
second banner but I think this is the
same company it's the same set of
quality standards there's no difference
there it's just a fresh new format that
I think will allow us to take those
standards into markets and communities
perhaps that Whole Foods Market never
would have been able to go so I would
argue it's a way of broadening our
appeal and broadening our footprint in
the world and Whole Foods is a play this
new strategy is somewhat of a play to
pulling these Millennials you put this
strategy in place before this year but
as you look at the global markets as you
look at the US economy how do you see
things well I think you know there's the
the macro situation that we can all see
and look at the news this morning that
there's clearly some headwinds and some
choppiness out there in the total
markets but for Whole Foods mean we're
focused on a very particular part of
that economy which is the grocery food
economy which is you know close to a
trillion dollars in total value and
there's lots of growth opportunities on
the natural organic healthy food side of
things which is we see growing double
digits as a market so Walter let's talk
about those headwinds a little bit I
think it's true I read you'll correct me
if I'm wrong that your same source sales
are actually down and your margins are
down does that make it more difficult
for you to pivot actually the the mark
the decrease in the margins is our pivot
we basically said over the next couple
years we're going to take the gross
margins down incrementally quarter to
quarter in conjunction with our cost
restructuring efforts which were well
underway in doing so the
strategic pivot is around reshaping the
company transforming the company to
compete better in the marketplace today
at the same time as continuing to launch
new digital platforms and new ways of
reaching our customers seeing that the
consumer could have less disposable
income in his or her wallet do we run
the risk that this positive trend we
have been seeing away from GMOs to more
natural organic foods could we lose that
while people are looking to cut personal
spending I don't think so because I
think people's personal health and
vitality Trump's that and I think we've
seen through many ups and downs over the
years that in the end people prioritize
food and the things that they're eating
at a higher level what you do see
sometimes they'll shift from the amount
of food spent out of the home to food
spent in the home but I think that
generally speaking this trend towards a
healthier Whole Foods is going to
continue unabated Walter let me take you
back moment to what Stephanie was
talking about these 365 stores who are
you hoping to take market share from
with those well there's an you see the
marketplace today there's a number of
smaller store competitors out there that
are taking that are doing a nice job per
ticking up serving customers you know
smaller sized or smaller sorts of offers
and we see we don't see any reason why
we can't go participate in that part of
the market as well with there are 365 by
Whole Foods offer it's going to be
unique it's going to be kind of a
combination of some of the best things
we do along with some of the things
we've learned from looking at the other
competitors and I think it's it's a
definitely an area that we can grow into
and reach more communities than we would
be able to with our mothership Whole
Foods Market as giants like Kroger and
Walmart who are all about low prices for
them low margins are getting bigger how
much of a threat is that to you how do
you expand while they are also expanding
and they've got a very big footprint
they do and they've done a nice job but
you know we're pretty good size too at
this point we'll be north of 16 billion
dollars in sales we have us on with 450
stores so we're not we're not playing in
the junior varsity ourselves and look
we've been competing with these folks
for an awful long time and their quality
competitors we think we're we still
think we offer the best in-store retail
experience for the customers in the
grocery space United States we think
we're the best at it
we think we do and I think the fact some
of our competitors have you
knowledge that so I think we'll continue
to offer sent a very clear high-quality
choice along with our new 365 by Whole
Foods Market choice I like our chances
and what's your biggest challenge today
well obviously the marketplace is going
through a tremendous short-term
adjustment as we have many new players
coming into the marketplace as everybody
realizes this is the type of food
general that people want and so what the
good news is you've got a market that's
overall growing for fresh healthy foods
the challenge for the market is worth
the non you know the non healthy food
stuff is collapsing on negatives but
this side the market is growing robustly
so I think it's just resetting ourselves
at a lower cost structure and evolving
some of our abilities to reach our
customers outside the store combining
that with our excellent in-store
experience to show up for our customers
when and where they want us to show up
for them are you going to need or look
to cut some of that special Whole Foods
experience because we're facing tougher
economic times
Whole Foods does have an extraordinary
experience customers love to go there is
that what you could look to cut back on
now I think our opportunities to do that
are much more on the structural side
we've looked at every we basically turn
our company upside down looking for ways
in which to kind of lower our cost
structure overall and again I think we
told you we're going to take out 300
million dollars by the end of 2017 we're
well on our way to doing that through
re-engineering the way we do work in the
store that were in and those are the
opportunities for us as opposed to going
right at you know the things that are
special to the customer experience